going to start by asking it briefly
about the news a day the supreme court
decision 62-43 in favor of upholding the
Affordable Care Act what would you say
in response that decision to Chief
Justice Roberts and what would you say
to your Republican colleagues who are
vowing to repeal the law look I think it
was the right decision I think it was
what it was consistent with the way we
voted in what we intended to vote for in
the Affordable Care Act but I would also
say that we are the only major country
on Earth that doesn't guarantee health
care to all people 35 million people
still have no health insurance the idea
of throwing 6.4 million people off of
health insurance would be totally absurd
and disruptive of the Affordable Care
Act so I'm happy with the decision
senator Sanders you did a press
conference today in which you unveiled
unveil the new plan dealing with the
estate tax there's a variety of things
that are involved there including ending
tax breaks for dynasty trust and
billionaires surtax I'm curious as to
whether the objective here is primarily
deficit reduction or whether it's
primarily about income inequality what
what's the what's the driving ambition
here of this plan we today have massive
and grotesque levels of income and
wealth inequality in the top one-tenth
of one percent now owns almost as much
wealth as the bottom ninety percent we
have got to address that issue and one
of the fairest the most straightforward
ways of doing it is through a
progressive estate tax it can raise
significant sums of money I can't tell
you exactly how much but it will be
significant sums and some of that money
has got to go to be invested in
rebuilding our infrastructure expanding
and supporting our childcare system
making college affordable for all of our
kids the rest of that could go to
deficit reduction this is not the first
time you've proposed in a state tax bill
you did that in 2010 in 2014 me neither
tight neither time did that go anywhere
what is it what's different this time
either in terms of the political
environment you're introducing it in or
in terms of your strategy of how to
actually get it passed no I don't think
it's going to get passed with a
Republican Republicans control the house
of the Senate I've never suggested that
but i think it is becoming more and more
apparent
the American people that something is
fundamentally wrong in this country when
so few have so much and so many have so
little so senator as you know we did a
poll because para Paul's one and I will
win in New Hampshire to try to get a
sense of how voters are thinking about
you you've got a quarter of the vote
about in both Iowa and New Hampshire up
from our previous polls in those states
and dependents are being pretty
supportive of you this morning on
Morning Joe I asked senator McCaskill
your colleague about you and your
chances I want you to listen to what she
said I think the media is giving Bernie
a pass right now I very rarely read in
any coverage of Bernie that he's a
socialist I think he would like to see
Medicare for all in this country he
would like to see expansion of
entitlement he would like to see he does
not worried about a debt at all he is
somebody who I think is frankly against
trade he's against a whole lot of things
yeah are unrealistic in this day and age
so senator I know you'd like to stay
away from personality and talk about
issues so let me ask you on the issues
senator McCaskill raised and suggested
they were part of your socialist beliefs
and made you unelectable guilty as
charged or you wanna you want to clarify
the record it's I find it surprising
that she says that the media doesn't
refer to me as a socialist is no article
that I've seen that doesn't refer to me
as a Democratic Socialist I am do I
believe in a medicare-for-all
single-payer system absolutely do I
believe in opposition to Senator
McCaskill that we need trade policies
that are fair to the American worker and
not just benefit CEOs of large
corporations I plead guilty I think we
need to change our trade policies we
couldn't think of another instance in
which one of your Democratic Senate
colleagues has spoken out against you
that way have you heard people speak out
against you that way and why do you
think senator McCaskill is now I to the
best of my knowledge this is the first
time that a colleague has attacked me
you'll have to ask senator McCaskill why
I think it's unfortunate I as you know
and I know I bore you guys sometimes the
death but I am trying to run
issue oriented campaign and not one of
personal attacks just to be clear
senator Sanders you never bore us you're
always a hundred percent delightful I
want to ask you a little bit more about
this poll and again we'll try to keep
we're in a state stick with issues but
just think about the you you've gained
ground in both Iowa and New Hampshire
and our poll and others on Hillary
Clinton we dug a little deeper though
and looked at some at some of the
underlying data and it's there's some
places where you're clearly behind her
one of them is with women where she
dominates you fifty nine percent to 19
and I was 64 to 19 in New Hampshire I'm
going to ask you to make the case to
female voters as to why you they should
support you day in particular should
support you over Hillary Clinton
especially given that she would be a
historic figure for that gender in and I
do understand that and you're absolutely
right there are millions of women who
are excited about the possibility of a
woman for the first time becoming
president of the United States I fully
understand that appreciate that I think
on the other hand if you look at my
economic agenda that says two women
workers you can't keep working for ten
or twelve dollars an hour we need to
raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars an hour we are going to unveil a
child care proposal for universal pre-k
which I think will make working families
all over this country extremely excited
because what we have now is a disaster
so senator beyond your rising to a
quarter of the vote in both Iowa and New
Hampshire you're doing well compared to
Secretary Clinton on the issue who's
more authentic on the issue of who would
take on Wall Street and other wealthy
interest but I want to ask you about
another one where you're not doing as
well as her and asked you to make the
case you said before you feel
passionately about your state tax
proposal but you said Republicans
control Congress can't get it done we
asked people in both states who can get
things done better in DC as president in
Iowa 64 211 Hillary Clinton over you in
New Hampshire sixty-seven percent said
Hillary Clinton fifteen percent you so
Republicans will probably control the
house in January is 2017 they may well
control the Senate even if you got
elected president make the case that you
can get more done than hillary clinton
in washington given the reality of
Republicans controlling the house that
is a very important question
and let me tell you what I say in every
speech that I give what I say is that
given the power of the billionaire class
corporate America Wall Street and
heavy-duty campaign contributors nothing
is going to happen to benefit working
families unless millions of people
around the country begin to stand up and
say enough is enough and what I have
said is that if elected president I will
be part of a nasmyth Minh which will be
strongly organized and very dynamic that
says to Congress we know what's going on
we are following what's going on and
you'd better vote to raise the minimum
wage to make college affordable to deal
with climate change to deal with income
and wealth inequality in other words it
is my view that no president not Bernie
Sanders not Hillary Clinton nobody is
going to deal with the needs of the
disappearing middle class unless we have
a new political movement in this country
that stands up and fights against the
billion at the power of the billionaire
class right sander sanders I'm going to
ask you another question about an issue
area where you're trailing senator
Clinton or Secretary Clinton and this
area you were being shellacked in our
poll which is foreign policy XP
experience in Iowa 80 for 23 of Hillary
Clinton leading and in New Hampshire 84
28 you are clearly to her left in terms
of national security in terms of foreign
policy I would say just it just again
explain why you think you're being
shellacked to that excites and what your
case is that you would be a better
foreign policy president that Hillary
Clinton good fair question the answer is
it goes without saying that when you are
the Secretary of State the United States
of America for four years by definition
you have an enormous amount of
experience in foreign policy no one can
debate that I was not Secretary of State
in fact I'm not on the Foreign Relations
Committee and I'm not on the Armed
Forces committee but this is what I will
tell you Hillary Clinton back in 2003
and I both have the same information
with regard to the wisdom of going into
Iraq not only that I vote against
war in Iraq but I helped lead the
opposition to that warrant I looked very
hard at the most important foreign
policy issue of the last several decades
and that is the war in Iraq I was right
on that issue Hillary Clinton was wrong
on that issue from